hasn't been a good week for the
mainstream media mob
an inspector general report recently
found that president trump did not order
officers
to clear and tear gas black lives matter
protesters
ahead of his visit to st john church
last year
this despite the army of fact checkers
and reporters
who reported the exact opposite dozens
of times
they might want to update their stories
meanwhile
twitter is having an absolute meltdown
over cnn's decision
to put legal analyst jeffrey toobin back
on the air
following his zoom masturbation scandal
last october
he returned to television yesterday and
attempted to set the story straight
in this painfully awkward interview on
cnn
take a look at this one i feel like we
should address
what's happened in the months since
we've seen you you were
on a zoom call with your colleagues from
the new yorker magazine
everyone took a break for several
minutes during which time
you were caught masturbating on camera
you were subsequently fired from that
job after 27 years of working there
and you since then have been on leave
from cnn to quote jay leno
what the hell were you thinking well
obviously
i wasn't thinking very well or very much
and
it was something that was inexplicable
to me i didn't think i was on
the call i didn't think other people
could see me
all right you mean to tell me that all
you have to do to redeem yourself in the
eyes of the far left media
is provide the defense that you quote
didn't think
other people could see you and as joe
koncha points out
what do these actions say to the women
of cnn
to real victims in the metoo movement
joining me now for some reaction is joe
koncha himself alongside fox nation host
tommy laron all right uh let's hear it
joe
what is your reaction to that well well
as far as
tuban is concerned i mean that's exactly
right as far as what are the women
of cnn now thinking when you think about
that just a couple weeks ago janine you
had chris cuomo
getting off on advising his brother
andrew cuomo democratic governor new
york on how to deflect and dismiss
sexual harassment allegations by
multiple staffers
some up to 35 years younger than him and
after this is revealed also by the way
after chris cuomo fakes his own
quarantine or after
he interviews his brother governor
doesn't uh at least a dozen times
without asking about the nursing home
scandal or he's caught coaching michael
cohen
about the questions he's going to get
the cnn interview and also gives him the
answers and after all that in aggregate
he gets no punishment but particularly
on advising his brother on how to
dismiss sexual harassment allegations
he was actually even rewarded a podcast
just last month so you're going to get
more
chris cuomo in this situation and also
you have to ask let's say if jeffrey
toobin was a lower level staffer or
let's say he was a woman or let's say he
was a conservative like i don't know
rick santorum does he get away with this
that is a rhetorical question janine and
the bottom line is
cnn is a boys club in prime time 8 p.m 9
p.m
10 p.m 11 p.m all male hosts that isn't
the case at fox
and that's not even the case at msnbc
and this is where we are right now you
could do whatever you wanted that
network and you will
get away with it you know but joe
it is just amazing to me that someone
would be on a zoom call
and actually do that i don't care if
they can see you or they don't see you
and he says i i don't know i wasn't
thinking yeah you were thinking about
something else what were you doing on
the call to begin with
i mean it's just so unfathomable tommy
what's your reaction
yeah listen if cnn wasn't a joke before
it is certainly a joke now
um also you know a lot of us in
mainstream media
now we have home studios i can't imagine
accidentally doing something like that
but furthermore let's take into account
the cancel culture mob that has gone
after
so many both inanimate objects and
people in the last six months to a year
and now imagine that this gentleman is
able to come back on and be on
mainstream media
and talk about how he's had a rough
seven months after doing what he did
and somehow we're supposed to feel badly
for him listen he has to have something
on somebody because
even cnn couldn't excuse that if not for
a greater reason
but the cancel culture mob would have
come after any conservative
and any other network they would have
come after them they would have been
done they would have to move to another
country
and never be in media again so that we
have to beg the question
where is the cancel culture mob where is
the metoo movement
where is alyssa milano you would think
they would be pretty upset about
something like this but sadly
they're not and you know tommy
the the interesting part of it is that
the
the the whole network cnn is now
tarnished
by what they've done and america sees
this they see it for what it is
you know there are a few things that you
can watch and say okay
i get that or you know it doesn't really
get into the mainstream
but joe you're in the media i mean you
know that this kind of thing i mean it
has to hit ordinary americas
when americans where they see the
difference between the way the standards
that the left is held to which is no
standard than the right which is an over
standard completely and and it's
reflecting in
the viewership over at cnn right now
where they've lost nearly 80
percent of their prime time audience
janine since just the beginning of the
year 8
and 10 gone and how could anybody ever
watch
any segment with jeffrey toobin ever
again when this is the first thing
that's going to come to your mind
when he comes on the air and is look
it's not like
he's completely indispensable i'm pretty
sure there's no shortage as you would
know
on legal analysts in this industry that
can replace him
no not at all and to your point again
for him to say well i didn't know that
the camera was on
so this is a-okay if the camera isn't on
during a work meeting
with other female staffers and the new
yorker fired him right away
cnn continued to pay him for the eight
months that he had this extended
vacation it's unbelievable
well and and tommy i want to change
subjects and talk about what happened at
the church at st
john's last year when they said that
trump had ordered the the park to be
cleared so we could go to the church
and they tear gas these uh uh black
lives matter protesters
uh that turns out certainly not to be
the case and i haven't heard of any
retractions i haven't heard anyone
saying i'm sorry
i mean it is it's just a lie and there's
no consequence in journalism for any of
this
go ahead tommy all they did for the
entire trump administration was lie
lie lie because they were doing the
bidding for the democrat party and they
still
are and these networks all they have to
rely on truly is their trump arrangement
syndrome now that is starting to fade
out
now that they no longer have donald
trump in the white house but at the end
of the day the american public is the
one that loses here when they look at
the media and then not only they do not
see a retraction but this should be
headline making news
if they had gotten this wrong about a
democrat something especially to this
magnitude we know that there would be
headlines about this it would be
breaking news all over
but at the end of the day we know that
the mainstream media does the bidding
for the democratic party
they only care about the narratives that
destroy conservatives and especially
that
destroy donald trump so we're not going
to see anything made of this at the end
of the day at the time it was happening
we knew it was a lie president trump was
saying that this was untrue
but nobody cared and that's the state of
journalism today they're on their
four-year vacation and we the american
public
we are truly the losers and those that
just listen to the mainstream media like
cnn
msnbc they're losing on a daily basis
and i feel very badly for those
individuals
that only watch that news you know joe
you're the media person here i mean when
the
e let's assume there's a fact checker
somewhere in the group
do they all say who cares let's just
sink them
so that joe joe biden can use this
against donald trump
at president donald trump at the time at
the debate
i mean somebody on the left had to know
it wasn't true
or do all of them know it's not true and
they just do it anyway
that's the thing the lockstep between
cnn
and msnbc and abc and cbs and the
washington post and the new york times
all confirming the others reporting not
one going in
in another direction saying hey wait a
minute we can't reconfirm
that the president ordered that tear gas
be used all of them in lockstep no one
was going to wait for the ig report by
the way
which was done over months of period of
time it was meticulous and conclusive
yet you have cnn anchor
the cartoonish jim acosta actually
attacking
the inspector general here saying that
he's
auditioning to be inspector general at
mar-a-lago oh that's lol funny he offers
nothing tangible of course
to dispute the report unless you know
sophomore year snark
is considered tangible in these
situations so here you have three years
of the media
working from a guilty until proven
innocent posture with donald trump of
russia collusion that didn't exist
stories of russian bounties on u.s
troops that never happened
or hunter biden's emails remember those
from his abandoned laptop
that was uh deemed russian
disinformation until it was and dozens
of examples of pushing
narratives against trump or
conservatives and these aren't mistakes
by the way
when it happens this often it's
intentional janine
yeah because they never make a mistake
the other way joe anyway joe tommy
thanks so much for being with us
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else